قال الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش ان العلماء والخبراء دعوا للتحرك
كما اعلنوا ان الذكاء الاصطناعي تهديد
وجودي للبشريه لا يقل عن الحرب النوويه
واشار غوترش الى ان التهديد العالميه الذي
يشكله الذكاء الاصطناعي يتطلب عملا عالميا
واضحا ومنسقا منسقا واكد ان هناك امكانات
هائله في استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن من
الواضح ان هناك مشاكل خطيره ايضا تتمثل في
امكانيه الغاء قرار البشر وايد المسؤول
الاممي فكره انشاء وكاله دوليه معنيه
بالذكاء الاصطناعي على غرار الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
في غضون ذلك اعلنت منظمه اليونسكو ان
الولايات المتحده طلبت العوده الى المنظمه
التي غادرتها في فتره الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب وسيخضع طلب الامريكي لتصويت
سري وقالت المديره العامه لليونسكو اودر
ازولاي امام ممثلي دول الاعضاء في
اليونسكو ان الولايات المتحده ابلغتها
رسميا قرارها العوده الى المنظمه وذلك
اعتبارا من شهر يونيو تموز المقبل
ونقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان قرار
العوده الى منظمه اليونسكو مدفوع بالقلق
من اتساع دور الصين في سياسات المنظمه
لاسيما وضع معايير عالميه لاستخدام الذكاء
الصناعي
انضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره مراد
هاشم مراد مدى وافع هذا القلق الاممي الذي
عبر عنه غوتيرج والذي فيما يبدو انه قلق
امريكي كذلك يدفع الولايات المتحده الى
العوده مجددا الى اليونسكو
نعم وسيله من الواضح ان الامم المتحده
والتحديدا الامانه العامه للامم المتحده
متمثله في الامين العام ترغب في ان تقوم
هذه المنظمه الدوليه التي تمثل الاطار
الدولي للعمل التعددي
الرئيسي في العالم بان تلعب دورا مهما او
في تنسيق جهود الدول للتعاطيل مع ما قد
يمثله الذكاء الصناعي من
من مخاطر الامين العام للامم المتحده
الدقه الجرس الانذار في الواقع في كلمته
بهذا الشان اليوم في مقر المنظمه وهو قال
ان هناك فرصا يخلقها الذكاء الصناعي ذكر
في مجال التعليم والصحه والبيئه
داعيا للاستفاده من هذه الفرص ولكنه ايضا
ذكر بالتحذيرات التي اطلقها العلماء
والخبراء الذين طوروا الذكاء الصناعي
انفسهم حينما قال ان هؤلاء خبراء دعوا
العالم الى التحرك وانهم قالوا ان هناك
حاجه الى تحرك دولي فاعل وان المخاطر التي
يشكلها الذكاء الصناعي اتصل الى مستوى
خطوره الاسلحه النوويه على البشريه
وقال انه سوف يشكل هيئه استشاريه بهذا
الشان قال ان هناك حاجه الى ان تكون هناك
وكاله تعنى بهذا الامر لكنه قال ان انشاء
وكاله ليس من اختصاصات الامان العمل للامم
المتحده ولكن على الدول الاعضاء ان تتحرك
حينما سئل عن ما اذا كان سوف يدعو الى قمه
قال انه لن ينافس دوله عضو بالفعل دعت الى
قمه حول الذكاء الصناعي وهو بطبيعه الحال
كان يشير الى بريطانيا ولكنه قال ان هذا
الموضوع وهذه التهديدات التهديدات ومخاطر
الذكاء الصناعي ستكون موضوعا رئيسيا في
قمه التنميه المستدامه التي ستعقد
بالتزامن مع فعاليات الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده الثانويه في سبتمبر المقبل فيما
يتعلق ايضا بالموضوع المرت هنا
بالذكاء الصناعي وهو قرار اداره بايدن
العوده الى منظمه اليونسكو في الواقع كان
هناك توقعات بهذا الشان اداره بايدن عاده
اداء العديد من المنظمات وعلى راسها مجلس
حقوق الانسان كما هو معروف وكانت اعتمدت
في يناير بدايه هذا العام مبلغ 150 دولار
من اجل التسويه ماليه مع
اليونسكو اذ ان هناك مديونيه متراكمه كما
هو معروف على الولايات المتحده بسبب
خلافاتها مع المنظمه الطويله والتي تمتد
لاربعه عقود على خلفيه قضايا عديده وبينها
القضيه الفلسطينيه الصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني بطبيعه الحال المعروفه ان اداره
انسحبت في 2017 من اليونسكو وبدايه من
2018 بدا سرايا هذا الانسحاب الان بعد خمس
سنوات الولايات المتحده تطلب العوده وهناك
ميزانيه مخصصه وترتيبات قدمت للمنظمه بشان
كيفيه هذه العوده والتفاصيلها والتفاصيل
المدفوعات الامريكيه فيما يتعلق هذه
المديونيه وسيله شكرا جزيلا لك مراد هاشم
مراسلنا من واشنطن